some people described me and my mom as
each other's soul mates
and we were
in the final months of her life Hannah's
mother Carmel was admitted to Hospital
in Birmingham while she was there Hannah
became increasingly concerned
I was told directly by my mum and I saw
the bruises
that she had had to throw herself out of
bed to be able to get to a drink Carmel
also suffered a fall in hospital it was
2021 and with covert restrictions in
place visiting was limited but when
Hannah did go in she was horrified
we'd been told that she hadn't got long
to live at this point and I lifted the
blanket
to find
oh God
a massive pool of
blood
absolutely disgusting that someone could
be left in such a state in the middle of
the hospital
it's not fit for purpose at the moment
she made a formal complaint in November
the hospital has said its review of the
case is still ongoing and it will
respond to the family as soon as
possible it's apologized for the delay
this all happened at the Queen Elizabeth
Hospital in Birmingham where last month
a damning report highlighted ongoing
problems
the report found that the culture among
staff is so toxic here that it could be
putting patients at risk it's prompted
people who feel angry about things that
they've seen and experienced in this
hospital to speak out
former Soldier Paddy Gallagher is among
them
I witnessed on multiple Wards on
multiple occasions during multiple
admissions elderly vulnerable patients
being left just being left in their own
urine and excrement their attitude
towards you makes you feel almost like
you don't deserve the treatment you're
getting
a spokesperson for University Hospitals
Birmingham said we aim to provide the
best possible care however we
acknowledge that we do not always get it
right and we're sorry where any patient
or family feels there is cause to raise
concern
but there are still two further reports
yet to be published on the problems at
one of England's largest NHS trusts
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham